so good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
my name is aina Badawi and it's my great
pleasure to be engaging in this
conversation with two giants I won't be
standing on your shoulders but that's
the name of this conversation standing
on the shoulders of giants but I'll be
sitting between you and said which is
far more preferable I think Patti Smith
really absolutely wonderful to be here
with you as so many people here admired
you from afar for many many years and
now from close up Here I am yeah great
here we are yes and professor Sir Angus
Deaton whom I'm sure many of you know
was last year's Nobel laureate for
economics and you won your prize for
poverty consumption and Welfare but
aren't you relieved I'm not going to be
asking you about any of that today
slightly different things you know if
you know something about poverty
consumption and welfare where you can
tell me later thank you so Patti Smith
obviously your career is one that's been
applauded in just about every corner of
the world but what I think has struck so
many people about you is the fact that
you have married poetry with your music
and that is something which a lot of
people have derived a great deal of
enjoyment from in terms of influences
and influences perhaps give us an idea
of what has inspired you well first of
all funny enough when I was a little
girl I wanted to be a scientist and and
help the world so I'm so glad that you
are doing the work that you are doing
because it was a little beyond me but I
do what I can
and I I when I realized that I was never
going to be a scientist I I found that
my vocation was writing and I read so
much as a young girl and I was inspired
and influenced by you know everyone I
read whether it was Paul de croo for or
is a mail cut and and as I evolved and
wanted to perform my poetry I was very
influenced by Allen Ginsberg and Bob
Dylan people that brought all of their
poetic imagery and merged it with a
worldview with the things that concern
us all and so I have many many
influences but there's two of them well
you've mentioned Bob Dylan and I believe
you you turd very briefly with him in
the in 1995 in the mid 90s and of course
he's this year's a literature laureate
and I know you're a big fan of Bob Dylan
to Professor Sir Angus Deaton so did you
find the fact that his music like
patties has this you know message in it
there's a kind of almost political
activism you could say it's not just the
The Beatles you know I love you and that
kind of thing I think John Lennon would
have something to say about that the
early Beatles
sorry the early Beatles maybe well
certainly you know Bob Dylan was an
inspiration to much of my generation and
there was suddenly this sense of global
justice which was a very important part
of his sound and his music always seemed
to me to somewhere that came from
somewhere completely different and that
it's like listening to Mozart where you
feel that Mozart is sort of a vessel for
what you're listening to because it's
hard to believe that some a human being
like the rest of us could constructed
this and Bob Dylan at that time seemed
to encapsulate for many of us the heirs
of the time I mean the views of the time
everything that was in the air at that
time and you know he obviously didn't
tell me to become an economist or
whatever but I mean he certainly did
like many of us make us wanted to make
the world a better place and I found my
way very indirectly into doing that and
you know like Patti when I was a kid I
wanted to be a scientist and that I
discovered that reading books was my way
into this and so I was certainly very
inspired by that very early on and was
living in a place where there was not a
lot of that around well that's
interesting you say that because it's
not just people but it's often
circumstances that it can influence you
and I'm sure you weren't my my saying
that you have written about how you were
brought up in rather impoverished
circumstances your father was a coal
miner originally your mother a waitress
and in fact not only did she not
encourage you to study she actively
discouraged you to study and you kind of
in a sense rebelled against your
circumstances because you wanted to do
something so circumstances can also
really fashion certainly very much
important my mother
being a nurse and then was this
homemaker so she she I don't think she
was ever well I'm sorry yes there's many
things by my mother
we'll get that straight III only
rebelled against half of it because my
father having been not educated himself
was very very keen that I be educated
my mother didn't really see the point in
it but in circumstances too I was
fortunate to grow up in the city of
Edinburgh in Scotland which was you know
in some ways a very deprived place but
it had this you know going back to the
Scottish Renaissance very much this
history of philosophy of literature of
scientific endeavor and it was a place
where you really were encouraged to
believe in yourself to read to
understand and it also literature in the
libraries in Edinburgh offered me a
vision of an exciting bright world out
there that was very different from the
world in which I was crying does that
resonate with you well I was from a
lower middle-class family I I lived in a
rural community and there wasn't it
wasn't much work the people struggled
but I was surrounded by my household was
there was always dialog books everywhere
and I you know was very stimulated by
the energy and my family they were
open-minded we didn't have anything but
I had a very open-minded upbringing but
I wanted to say one thing when you were
talking about listening to Bob Dylan
when you were young and choosing your
vocation today I was reading things
about about your what your field is and
what you all the things that you do and
it made me think of lines that I was
learning in hard rain's gonna fall
because he said where which would have
he wrote in 63 or something where the
people are many where their hands are
all empty
where
hunger is ugly where souls are forgotten
and that is the way you know an artist
does his work in articulating the
troubles of our world and and then the
scientists and researchers and people as
yourself actually go out to do something
about it so it's a in that way we're all
hopefully working toward the same thing
hmm so you use your music obviously as
you said Bob Dylan has to kind of get
the message you know anti-poverty and
you you could be described as suppose as
as an activist we know that in in one
presidential American election you
backed Ralph Nader the the green
candidate and I wonder if because
there's been a great deal of
conversation and debate since the
victory of Donald Trump in the
presidential election with people
talking about how that reflects how
America perhaps has become a more or is
a polarized society and then you've got
two very different visions exactly what
the question is but yes we are very
polarized we are historically polarized
even the way we vote only half of the
country really votes and the other half
are polarized so when we have a
president one doesn't always get a sense
of who is voting for that person but the
election of Donald Trump tells us many
things about our country one is there is
a very strong dissatisfied faction who
feels that no one is speaking to them
and also the the rise and importance of
social media and even celebrity culture
in our country so this is a this
election with you know which was
conducted very poorly caused huge
amounts of
that should have gone really to the
underprivileged and with the results
should be a real wake-up call for the
whole world and especially for my
country and and future candidates that
you have to understand you're speaking
to all the people not affection of the
people and especially you've got to
speak to people who are dissatisfied
feel marginalized and and there can't be
an elitist concept in democracy hmm I
mean sir Angus we saw in the brexit
debate how expert opinion particularly
of the economists who by and large at
least the mainstream ones back the
remained campaign and we saw how
obviously the vote went the other way
that people were choosing to disregard
expert opinion as it were in in favor of
something else and and patty has just
talked about how you know you can't
ignore the voices as that as they speak
is that something that concerns you that
experts perhaps don't quite have the
same currency that they have had in the
past well that's certainly true that
experts don't have as much currency and
in many ways they don't deserve as much
currency because they've claimed
territory that is not their own and
they've sort of tried to substitute
expertise for politics and saying you
should behave this way or you should do
this way and imposing solutions on
people where science really doesn't have
the answer at all but the first thing I
was going to say to you was you know
when you look at this what do you feel
and what I feel is boy did we do a
really bad job you know and in some
sense you know we came out of you know
that when we were talking about Bob
Dylan or what we felt in the 60s there
was this sort of feeling of a world had
gone badly wrong and that many many
things needed to be corrected and many
of us were inspired in very many
different ways to go into music or to go
into art or to go into
like so or whatever to try and make that
world a better place and I think we've
learned a lot since then I mean I
certainly know a lot more than I did
then and I think you know the fields in
which I work have made a lot of progress
too but we somehow fail to either this
doesn't properly connect with these
people or we haven't tailored it in a
way that's relevant to them one of the
things I think is very badly broken and
I think this is true in both the UK and
the u.s. is that the working class has
very little political representation
today there used to be unions at America
nowadays there are no unions at America
- first approximation in Britain the
Labour Party used to consist of people
who were elected from the unions to
represent working people in Parliament
nowadays the Labour Party is educated
liberal elites who think of themselves
as representing those people they are
not all of those people and I think a
lot of what's happened in Washington is
partly the two political parties have
moved in to where the money is and away
from where the people yeah you've done a
lot of research on the states and how
white communities in the parts of the
states they occupy form a
disproportionate number of the
disaffected the premature deaths and
coincidentally also those who backed
Trump mostly so that seems to be a new
scenario of discussion there's real
distress in those communities hmm we've
talked about some of the the public
things but I know when I spoke to you
briefly yesterday patty about what you'd
like to talk about and what has shaped
you and influenced you use that our
motherhood is the something that's very
important to me and it's it's very funny
because when I was a young girl all I
wanted to be as I grew up was an artist
I never thought about having children I
thought there were many children in the
world and I just wanted to create art I
just wanted to do my work but I fell in
love
and my husband really wanted children
and so I had a son and daughter and I'm
a responsible person and I thought well
I'll raise my children but a very
strange thing happened I fell in love
with my children I I was the oldest of
four children and helped raise my
siblings and it it came very natural to
me now my son and daughter their father
died young and so I have a strong bond
with my children and I learned from them
and are influenced by them continually
my son because my son is just a good man
he's a simple man very good and he's got
a moral quality that always makes me
question and remember why I'm doing
things and my daughter is more of a
social more of an activist than I she
works for awareness of climate change
she works with immigrants she works with
Tibetan and Nepalese musicians she's
constantly working to help others and
when I get to you know wrapped up in my
own world and and just in in my own
solitude both of them remind me of you
know certain human responsibilities my
son is a father and so he comes to me
for advice about his his child and my
daughter is an activist and she comes to
me counselling me you forgot to recycle
hey what are you doing today you should
do a benefit here so I am constantly in
I have two very good influences right in
my own backyard
you've also influenced them along with
your late husband Fred Smith who of
course was very famous guitarist I think
Rolling Stone magazine said he's one of
the
100 greatest guitarists of all time
and your son plays the guitar Jax 101 at
least and and good and Jessie your
daughter also plays the piano so
obviously you and their late father have
also influenced and is that something
that pleases you that they've picked up
since their father was the real musician
I'm I sing but I don't really have any
accomplishment in an instrument
I really am more of a writer performer
they really channel their father and
when we're together the three of us can
always be with him through music he is
never really departed for us and when
we're playing together I can hear his
tones in my son's guitar I can hear his
creativity and my daughter's choices and
but I feel his influence remains always
with that with them it's within their
blood and I know the ways that I've
influenced them but I it makes me even
happier truthfully when I see his
influence upon them when I'm sure you
have influenced so many people and given
great pleasure to so many people and
inspiration all over the world just a
final work you sir Angus Bob Dylan this
years literature laureate but he's not
here a matter of regret for you very
much so yes you would have liked of
shaking hands and shaking his hand
yes and for me it's a wonderful thing
because I think you know no vowels
original intention of doing good for
mankind also depends on how many people
you do good for and you know not
everybody likes Bob Dylan as much as I
do but he's changed and influenced
millions of people's lives and the
recognition of that by the Nobel
foundation I think it's just a wonderful
thing
professors Angus Deaton thank you and
Patti Smith of course thank you very
much indeed to
[Applause]